welcome to edna
we have
let's see we will be executing a number
of bills after we complete the public
hearing on house bill 1321. i call the
sponsor representative horrigan
yes representative horrigan if you're
going to give us testimony which i very
much appreciated i would also appreciate
you're not reading it to us
every member of this committee has
passed the literacy test
well thank you i'll try to make it
somewhat extemporaneous um
hopefully i won't digress too much
actually
that will enable me to skip ahead to
skip ahead till the end which is the
second section of the bill is which will
look very very similar to you because
it's the same as hb 1037 which you
amended and improved and i think it's
already reports already been filed and
thank you very much for your work on it
and you made it better i'm
the one this is probably somewhat
duplicative the way i did it but i ols
when i consult with ols i figured the
part that's section two would be more
less controversial than what's in
section one and uh so they
we ended up sending two bills down and
nobody stopped me the speaker's office
didn't stop me whoever else is
responsible so that's why i had two
bills and
i'd assumed at the time that we'd
probably have the hearing it on the same
day for both bills but um that's
yes okay that's why so
and um so
we're basically rolling back
um well really back to changes to rsa
445 subpar uh roman numeral one and two
so they're in uh section 91 459 of the
budget trailer bill and then um they're
also
and that um
basically that part of the rsas and they
had two sections um of the house version
of the budget trailer bill
which were then dealing with the
emergency powers uh governance emergency
powers issues and then the senate took
those out and then they
had a very different version
[Music]
was put back in during the conference
committee so the language that's in uh
that was sections 459 and 460 of the
um budget trailer bill were never
never let never had a hearing because
you know it was uh introduced put in at
the last moment during the conference
committee and that's uh
and that's the way that's the way things
happen with a lot of issues that's not
nothing terribly nefarious about it but
i um
but i disagreed with at least half of
what they did so i'm um
just restoring rsa 445 roman numeral one
and 2 to what was passed into law along
with many other emergency management
provisions
20 years ago in 2002 by a broad
bipartisan majority
i guess it was a
roll call in the house which was
something like 238 to 112 but they were
across party lines uh both on the gays
and nays and that so
and it's been um
been the same ever since until now so
that was they added some stuff to rsa 4
then they also created rsa21p and now
i'm getting way off into the weeds and
that was a reaction at the events of
september 11 2001
and i think the law has been passed
well as work since then including during
the uh
well i described here as a 20 21 20 yeah
the 2020 and 2021 state of emergency and
um there's some i think
actually the crisis that led to the
estate emergency going on but the uh the
governor uh imposed a state of emergency
as you all remember all too well back in
uh mid march of 2020 and then he uh
continued for 15 months um even and then
he rather uh
abruptly
didn't renew it in june 2021 but anyway
so the pandemic is a different type of
crisis from what was envisioned in 2022
but i think well 2002 i mean but i think
the law
worked well i mean i don't necessarily
agree with everything sununu dead fact
disagree with a lot of it
but i actually thought he wasn't tough
enough in certain levels certain areas
and also other cases he kind of stepped
a little bit outside the law in certain
areas and like he was reacting a crisis
and he didn't know what was going on any
more than i did or anybody else did so i
and uh
and there's some there's some
questionable things certainly he shut
the legislature totally out of the
emergency response process for several
months and then when we got back in he
kind of we kind of set up our own
legislative body but um the law
the but the bill the budget trailer bill
did a little stuff
excuse me representative horrigan you're
rambling oh sorry well that was
i know well i'm trying not to read it
verbatim so
and um
anyway the changes did very little
address that issue and i think the
process that eventually passed by the
conference committee is cumbersome and
wouldn't work it certainly would not
have worked two years ago which was uh
we'd be forced to meet every 90 days in
joint session along with the senate
to renew the state of emergency um even
if there's a bipartisan consensus that
the emergency state of emergency should
continue
and even it's not necessarily possible
for us to meet and presumably be in
person and that's an even more of a
difficulty uh
the house did meet
at the whittemore center arena in 2020
as those of you here remember vividly
but that was about 90 days
after the state of emergency was imposed
but we can't necessarily count on that
happening the next time something
similar happens to the state of new
hampshire and i'm sure
someday it will so
um
anyway so i just thought so that even
though like so i thought the old law was
just permits us to meet if we just feel
like the governor is wrong in the state
of emergency
because existing law does allow us to uh
call it call ourselves a joint
convention and terminate the state of
emergency if that's what there's a
consensus to do and if it's possible for
us to meet a joint convention i think
that was uh better than
better than what we had so i urge you to
uh
pass this bill um since half of it
you've already passed and reported you'd
there's obviously you'd have to deal
with that some way probably my
simplest solution probably would simply
to be uh
to take the amended language that you've
already passed and then paste it into
this bill so that's um
so that's basically uh that's basically
my proposal i'm just i think what we did
in 2002 is better than what's in the
budget trailer bill at least for the
time being and this issue may have to be
revisited but it probably should be
revisited in a more leisurely and more
open fashion than a
budget conference committee so that's
so that's that's my proposal and i'd be
happy to take any questions
thank you are there questions
representative lackas
thank you um
you mentioned that you thought there
were some things the governor did that
might have been inappropriate and so
given that
um wondering why you chose to remove the
legislature's ability
to uh repeal individual emergency orders
which is in uh current statute after uh
you know our last year well my belief is
and i looked at the
old stature that we already had that
power it was just
it was
it was optional so we
felt
if we felt that we should meet in joint
convention we could still call ourselves
in the joint convention but this would
make us do so even if um
even if there was a
even if they're even uh if even if the
consensus was to continue the state of
emergencies obviously so there already
is a provision in there i believe for
the house to uh house and senate to come
together and follow up sure
um you might want to look at it because
i as i understand it and you know maybe
you can correct me um
we could meet and end the entire state
of emergency but we did not have the
authority to uh terminate individual
emergency orders
uh well that's uh
that
i'm not sure but i'm not sure if i i'm
not sure if i agree with that or not but
uh there's that's uh probably
that's probably something that that
should be uh should be uh should be
considered certainly
certainly if we meant it
certainly um there are lots of ways we
could bring bring pressure on him and i
also felt that the governor you know
he kind of bypassed uh there's the
fiscal committee which uh
my opinion should have
should have uh
done the then should have continued its
role and said he set up a uh you know
the
advisory committee
the gopher i believe it was called uh
yes thank you that was that was one of
the specific emergency orders that many
members of the legislature wished to
terminate without terminating the entire
yes emergency yeah the problem i mean
there is there's certainly his way if we
probably could have uh
i think this probably weighs the threat
of terminal state of emergency could
would probably make uh
certain would make the governor uh
rethink some of his or her actions in a
future emergency so
thank you representative horrigan i have
two a question for you yes did you
consider the language of house bill 417
which passed last year on a 328 to 41
vote
um oh that was uh
i considered it but this is the proposal
i i came up with so you can certainly um
thank you i mean
yes or the house bill 275 which we
passed in january
well in january this january was this
january well this had not passed when i
uh
submitted
obviously that would not have passed
back in november december when i was uh
drafting the bill
any other questions
all right thank you for your testimony
oh thank you so thank you for your
patience representative vlasic
thank you madam chair members of the
committee i'm melissa blasik i represent
hillsborough 21 the town of merrimack
i am here today to oppose hb 1321 this
bill undoes much of our achievements
last year to reform state of emergency
statute
rsa 445 was originally passed in 2002 as
a response to 911 and was not
implemented until the recent covet 19
state of emergency
after the law was used we saw room for
improvement for future emergencies the
changes we made that you see today in
existing law are not a reflection in any
way upon how the executive branch
managed the covet 19 state of emergency
they are simply a response to lessons we
learned
the state of emergency reform we
achieved last year should not be
considered a partisan issue
both parties value our constitutional
form of government that has created the
freest society on earth to quote thomas
jefferson the republican is the only
form of government which is not
eternally at open or secret war with the
rights of mankind
it therefore follows that we maintain
this form of government with its
separate branches that create checks and
balances upon each other in some fashion
even during a state of emergency
i find it confusing why anyone would
object to the reforms we made last year
how is it bad that the legislature can
terminate a particular emergency order
while maintaining a state of emergency
doesn't this protect people from
potential abuses of authority while
allowing their elected representatives
to do their job and represent the people
what's wrong with the government needing
to be notified that the legi
needing to notify the legislature of an
emergency order how is it objectionable
to change the termination of the state
of emergency to a simple vote instead of
a resolution resolutions have
limitations as to when they can be
introduced so changing this to a simple
vote makes more sense
calling for this vote after a certain
period of time and again allowing the
elected representatives to represent the
will of their constituents in allowing a
suspension of a normal functioning state
government seems completely logical to
me
and yet this bill seeks to undo all of
this i urge you all to give this an itl
recommendation
thank you representative blasek are
there any questions
i don't see any so thank you very much
thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on house bill 1321
okay not seeing none i'll close the
public hearing
all right and i will open our executive
session
unfortunately the amendment to house
bill
1535 had a typo
so it is being revised
yes
1535.
that one had a as i said had a typo
and it
is being revised so we will not take it
up until we have the amendment
okay
let's start off with something we can
agree on
that's we need to tomorrow
who
i i'd like to present
or actually representative
yakubovic is presenting an amendment to
house bill 1497
he needs two
thank you madam chair
so this is the representative lanzaro's
bill
and we worked on the language in the
subcommittee and worked in it some more
afterwards
and we actually incorporated the
language from
uh representative golly's bill into it
1557 i believe so this is
a joint effort from everybody
many members of the committee
and some outside groups and this is what
we have and i think we should pass it
because this is the best version of
everything we've got
thank you
make a motion to pass otp
pass accept adopt this amendment thank
you okay that is amendment 0.437h
to house bill
1497 second
okay
goalie
kubovitch has already spoken to his
motion representative goldie do wish to
speak to you
second
uh real briefly madam chair um
just want to note that
well
ols didn't put the language i had in my
bill exactly into this amendment i'm not
sure why
but in speaking with marty carlin with
the retirement system i think it will do
the same thing as was originally
intended and we should be okay with it
okay thank you very much is there any
further discussion on amendment0437
all right seeing none the motion is
ought to pass and the clerk can call the
roll
yes
representative yakovich yes
representative
yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative lonzara yes
representative santo nastasso yes
representative goalie
yes
representative schuett
representative judy oui
representative
marsh
yes
representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grote yes
representative o'brien yes and the chair
yes
looks like 18 to 0.
all right
on the adoption of women
so do you have
are you going to make a motion on the
the bill yes yes please make a motion
otpa on 1497.
second
goalie i believe
all right any further discussion
since the amendment replaces the entire
bill there certainly too much
seeing seeing none the motion is ought
to pass with amendment on house bill
1497 and the clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes
yes
the clerk votes yes representative
pearson yes
representative jacob yes representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes
representative lonzarra yes
representative santo nastaso yes
representative goalie
yes representative sherwood
yes representative judy
representative schmidt
sorry he's not here representative marsh
yes
representative fellows yes
representative fondo yes representative
grota
yes
representative o'brien yes and the chair
yes 18 again to zero
all right motion passes 18 to zero
any uh
objections to consent
right seeing none we'll put that one on
consent
all right i moved to reconsider our vote
on house bill
1557 which we voted ought to pass
i'll second reconsider
and i'll just mention that since we
folded the language of house bill 1557
into
we don't want to have two bills on the
same subject floating around
representative pearson do you wish to
speak to your second
uh
absolutely not that was uh exquisite
all right any
other comments from goalie
thank you madam chair and
i agree with that reconsideration
made the motion seconded by
representative pearson to reconsider our
vote of ought to pass on house bill 1557
the reconsideration motion uh the clerk
can call the role
representative rhodes
yes
clerk votes yes representative pearson
yes representative jacobovich yes
representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes
representative lanzara yes
representative santo nestaso yes
representative goalie
representative stewart
yes representative judy we
representative marsh
yes
representative fellows
yes representative fontenot yes
represent grota yes representative
o'brien
yes the chair
yes
1918 to zero
to reconsider okay the motion
to be voted on is our ought to pass
motion which you are reconsidering
and i would urge everyone to vote no so
that we don't have the two bills
floating around with the same topic
any further discussion
um
we've already voted to reconsider i'm
just reminding people of what the motion
to be voted on is
it was made
some time ago i can't recall who made
the motion
i think so
the reconsideration is itl right
no
the procedural effect is that our
previous we voted to reconsider our vote
the previous motion that we voted on was
ought to pass
we have to vote against that in order to
make a different motion
thank you
question of the chair yes sir
just because i know this has come up in
the health and human services committee
when i was there has anyone ask the
house clerk if we're still in the time
frame where it's allowable to reconsider
i have not yes we are still in the time
frame until the bill has been forwarded
to the clerk
i have made sure not to forward it to
the clerk thank you for that
senator yes madam chair i just looked
back through my records and i showed
that we voted on that bill on january
25th
i don't know if anybody was absent but
that may be why you don't remember it if
you weren't here that day
yes it was it was a ways back but we did
vote on it it was unique i believe it
was unanimous
14 uh yes okay
fine
but in any event we are reconsidering it
and i urge you to vote no
the clerk can call the
representative representative rhodes no
clark foots no representative pearson no
representative yakovich
no
representative leckus no representative
allegro no represent bailey
no
represent representative lonzara no
representative santo nastaso no
representative goalie no
representative schuett no
representative judy no
representative marsh
no representative fellows
no
representative font no no
representative grota
no
representative o'brien
no the chair
no
0 to 8 19
18. did i say it i'm sorry
okay the motion fails representative
goalie you have an alternative motion
interim study
and i'll second that
we should speak to your motion
real briefly i think uh we have a
language before us and i think it's
important to keep it an interim study in
case anything happens over in the senate
that we haven't voted this and
recommended at itl
okay thank you aguirre goalie yep i'm
i'm not going to say anything because
representative goldie's expressed it
perfectly clearly
the motion is interim study
any discussion
okay i don't see any
so the clerk can call the role
representative rhodes yes
clark votes yes representative pearson
yes representative jacobovich yes
representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lunzara yes representative santo
nastasso
yes representative goalie
yes
representative schuett
representative judy oui
representative marsh yes
representative fellowes
yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota yes
representative o'brien
yes
and the chair
18 to 0. okay the motion of interim
study passes
18 to zero
uh we will keep this
in hand in case in case of disaster in
the in the other body
and we'll put this on consent i'll need
a
short report from representative goalie
all right
representative lekkis you have a motion
on house bill 1563
um
yes uh my motion is uh itl
for a second
second
by
lack is seconded by rhodes
do you wish to speak to your motion
uh yes just a moment so um
trying to look through my notes we uh
the subcommittee met and um dealt with
this um
there were
a number of concerns i mean
i don't feel strongly one way or another
about this but there were concerns that
um
it might not be the appropriate um you
know in the best interest of some
employees uh you know depending on
whether they have debt or other issues
um
and there were some
views expressed that
trying to
nudge people or influence what they do
especially by the government through
changing the defaults
wasn't necessarily appropriate
and um
and that people can choose to uh join
this if they want and adjust their
payment whenever they want so
it was viewed as not really uh necessary
now
if in the future you know the uh
executive departments or other other
parts executive uh
branch feel that there's some value to
this i mean they can ask for us to
consider doing it again but at this
point i recommend itl
thank you representative rhodes
thank you madam chairman
i don't have a whole lot of notes on
this particular bill except that it
seemed that the general overall
consensus of the committee really didn't
like it i do remember there were a lot
of questions asked and other than that i
would pretty much just refer to
everything that representative like us
had just mentioned
representative mark
yes i just want to expand on what
representative lekka says one of the
things we pointed out in subcommittee is
that this would specifically affect
younger employees or this is their first
job the intention is to nudge them into
saving sooner for their retirement
feeling that compounding would get them
ahead faster in life that would make
sense
in a lot of instances however in the
specific instances which is all too
common these days
where a new employee has higher interest
rate loans particularly student loans
it's far and away in their better
interest to first pay off their loans
and then start saving for their
retirement and therefore we didn't think
we should mandate that they
automatically be enrolled in this
system so thank you for that
well as a sponsor of this bill i thought
that there were enough
there wasn't enough language there to
allow people to adjust the plan
to suit their specific circumstances
and i think that in the future it should
be considered
but i
i
after thinking about it i think that it
would be more appropriate to be
initiated by
the the the executive branch say in the
governor's budget or in a contract
negotiation
and
then put into statute rather than being
a legislative initiative
um i think that's
really not so much our uh
our responsibility
representative fellows um thank you
madam chair i i definitely agree with
with the suggestion that you just made
particularly because it gives an
opportunity for the state employees the
people that we're talking about here to
have the input
as to what as to how it might work best
for them thank you
i do think that the fact that none of
them wrote us or called
or showed up at the hearing indicated
that they were not violently objecting
to it
it may not me they may not have had but
strong support but there was not violent
objection
i did speak with the
sciu
before i i brought it in so
they they were at least aware of it
representative schuett
thank you madam chair um i would just
like to say i i
am uh involved with deferred comp myself
and i think probably the better way to
go would be to
find some way to encourage
the state to better educate particularly
new employees
about the benefits of the system
i'm not sure how that can be
accomplished but i think that's
the thing we should look at
thank you
other comments questions representative
scitec
well everybody said every many
reasonable things but the fact is opt
out exists and
whether it's a personal circumstance
whether it's whatever reason they can
opt out and
people need to be more than nudged in my
view representative o'brien in his quiet
way said how important it was in his own
financial life i think representative
schuett might have also so i'm
i'm going to vote against itl
thank you
other comments from the committee
representative fellows
thank you
i certainly can't say what all private
companies do
but i know that in many cases
there are
private companies offer a match
to
deferred compensation plans
which provides an incentive for the
employees
to make an investment toward their
retirement
absolutely true and
nobody's suggesting the state makes such
a match
and the other representative psychic
this year anyway
thank you
any other comments
okay then the motion is inexpedient to
legislate on house bill 1563
and the clerk can call
yes
representative jakobovic yes
representative lekkis yes
representative allegro yes
represent bailey
yes
representative lonzara yes
representative santo nestaso yes
representative goalie
yes
representative schuett
yes representative judy
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota yes
representative o'brien yes
you're my last hope
yes
um
17 to zero one
you're not it's not zero representative
you count
thank you
sometimes i wonder
does anyone object to consent the motion
passed seventeen to one
person
you'd be the most obvious person to
object okay
with no without objection we'll put it
on consent
all right what else have we got
all right represent pearson do you have
a motion on house bill 1429
madam chair
there's an amendment coming to the
committee on 1429.
he will be here by noon
all right in that case we will hold off
on that one
[Music]
in that case i move
the amendment to house bill 1552
and
what's the amendment number
there are copies on the table and
everyone should have gotten them
all right
i didn't get a copy for myself hmm
okay thank you
right this is okay
um
right it's amendment number 519 h
is there a second
okay
thank you
this amendment addresses the issue
that came up at the hearing that the
functions of the of the some of the
functions of the assessing board
were being transferred to a
assessor certification board under oplc
but it didn't address
the
the transition
so this amendment simply says
that any dra issued certificate
is valid until it expires
and that a person coming in with such a
certificate will be considered as a
renewal rather than a new license
i didn't have to extend the rules for
from dra because
they still certified their own employees
and municipal assessors
so their rules are still still valid
they weren't
invalidated by moving moving the
functions of the board
representative marsha
yes if i could ask a question does this
address the concern of the test the
person who testified from goffstown that
there wouldn't be enough assessors to
actually
implement the property tax yes
it it keeps every currently certified
assessor certified
for the for the duration of their uh
current certificate thank you for that
pearson thank you um
and
this will this can certainly be
revisited when
when we look at um
the makeup of other boards i i
the only the only thing i would have
liked to have seen is is uh the
inclusion of alternates onto this board
since that seems to be something that
we're doing other than that i mean a
neck and like i said that could be
addressed at another time so
this definitely takes care of the
grandfathering problem and i think that
was the overall
biggest concern with this
any other comments on the amendment
all right seeing none the motion is
ought to pass amendment
0519 to house bill 1552
and the clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes yes
clark wrote yes representative pearson
yes
representative jacobovic yes
representative
yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lonzaro yes representative santo nastasa
yes representative goalie yes
representative show it
yes representative judy we
representative
marsh
yes
representative fellows yes
representative
fontno yes
representative grota yes
representative o'brien
yes the chair yes
18-0
on the amendment adoption of the
amendment okay the amendment passes
and i move out to pass with amendment on
house bill 1552
since representative schmidt's not here
is there a second
second
okay
representative goalie second
all right
and i'll i'll speak to my motion this
this bill moves the
professional assessors
to a new board
that is
and moves them out from under the
department of revenue administration
that helps because dra has
is not transparent they have
they're exempt for most
most of their actions are exempt from
91a
they also hire
and train assessors so having the the
regulation of assessors
as well
creates the possibility of a conflict of
interest
so i think that this board
is
more appropriately
associated with the oplc
and um
i hope you will support it
representative goalie do you wish to
speak to you
uh i think it was well said and
the order of transparency i think this
is the right thing to do
representative scitec
well i agree of course but i think that
it could have been done without uh the
whole setup of another board just to
make a exemption for
uh disciplinary procedure
transparency in the appropriate places
in dra as far as the conflict of
interest goes i've not ever heard or no
instance of that has ever been alleged
that i was aware of so i think this is
i'll vote for this but it seems a pretty
big contraption that's not necessary
okay thank you other comments
questions okay i don't see any
so the motion is ought to pass as
amended on house bill 1552 and the clerk
can call the roll
representative rhodes yes clerk votes
yes representative pearson yes
representative jakobovic yes
representative lectus yes representative
allegro yes representative bailey yes
representative lonzara yes
representative santo nestaso yes
representative goalie yes
representative schuett
yes
representative judy we
representative marsh yes
representative fellows
represent no yes
representative grota yes representative
o'brien yes and the chair yes
an unsullied 18-0
okay
the motion passes they're in the
objection to consent
okay very good
you have a motion on house bill 13-14
um
yes madam chair i motioned to itl
is there a second
i'll second it
okay
that was representative now
santa
um yes i spoke with the veteran groups
and um
uh they were trying to get an amendment
in and they were trying to figure out
what they want to do with this bill they
were not quite happy with the way it is
and
they do not have enough time to work on
it plus their board the association will
be changing to new
board of managers are going to undergo
significant changes
starting
in march of this year so they're
thinking
they need more time probably months to
work on this so they'll come back with
something else next year
that's why you know
representative
representative santana estacio do we
speak to your second
uh no
all right is there any further
representative grota
i did speak with the auditing department
and there were several audits that were
conducted on the veterans home and i
will share that link with the committee
so that we're well aware of the
situation there
thank you
i'd like to say that there are
undoubtedly issues with the veterans
home but i don't think a study committee
is the right approach
representative pearce thank you during
or slightly after
the initial testimony we were presented
made aware and were presented a
a study that occurred in 2014
that was
most of the members of which are no
longer in the
legislature with the exception of
senator carson
and we learned that the recommendations
of this board had really not been
enacted so
it seems as though they've already taken
a look at this they've got a little bit
of a road map here to
do some of these things and maybe they
should
work through the 2014
study
before piling on another one
yes thank you representative
thank you madam chair
i just recently read in the newspaper
that a new commandant has been appointed
at the veterans home also
so it seems wise to
let the new leadership settle down a
little bit before we look at doing
anything to the board thank you
yes thank you my opinion is that after
the study was released
they said we should take the world war
one veteran off the board and none of
the members of the of the study
committee nor anyone else
bothered to do that
i think that we need we need to uh
we shouldn't do another study it would
be just a waste of effort
any other comments
questions okay
seeing none the motion is an expediting
to legislate on house bill 1314
and the clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes yes
the clerk votes yes representative
pearson yes representative yakubovic yes
representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative lanzara yes
representative santo nestaso yes
representative goalie
yes representative schuett
yes
representative
judy
representative marsh
representative fellows yes
represent representative hunt no yes
representative grota
yes representative o'brien
yes
the chair
eighteen to zero
all right the motion passes eighteen to
zero
is there any objection to consent
excellent
okay
and
i'd like to move
interim study on house bill 1191
is there a second
house bill 1191 was my bill about
expanding the homeowner's exemption to
duplexes
the the
testimony at the hearing convinced me
that as written it was too broad
but it does deserve some
further study on the area of accessory
dwelling units
and also on the fact that the
homeowner's exemption
language for the various professions
is not consistent we need to look at
what the restrictions are
particularly in the plumbing code
and clean up a lot of that language and
i think interim study is a good
opportunity to do that
representative rhodes you wish to speak
the second thank you madam chairman i
actually no i think you said everything
exactly as i was thinking
any further discussion or comment
representative scitec
since this is an executive session and
this is somewhat relevant i've i'm going
to speak against the homeowner's
exemption because how can you
endanger your family if you are
an incompetent gas fitter
and does your family count less than a
stranger that i'm running across a
duplex
personally i'd like to see
the whole thing rewritten such that
homeowners can do anybody can do a like
for like
i replaced the garbage disposal like for
like there's nothing to it
essentially nothing to it
and but that's the end of my speech for
now
well interim study would give us a
chance to look at the whole topic
any other comments questions
all right in that case the motion is
interim study on house bill 1191 and the
clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes
yes
the clerk votes yes representative
pearson yes represents jacobovic yes
representative lekkis yes representative
allegro yes representative bailey yes
represent representative lonzara yes
representative santo nestaso yes
representative goalie
yes representative show it
yes representative judy oui
representative
marsh
yes
representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota
yes
representative o'brien yes
and the chair yes
it is 18 to 0.
any objections to consent the motion
passed 18-0
okay seeing none
representative fellows you have an
amendment and a motion on house bill
1427.
um
i i passed out an amendment um like a
week and a half two weeks ago i have i
do have um
three extra copies if anybody's missing
that
is amendment number 0244
h
so i'd like to move the amendment
is there a second okay representative
march seconds
it is amendment 2022-0244-h
represent fellows if you wish to speak
to the amendment okay
so the
the the original bill
simply added an audiologist to the board
because um
it was originally enacted last year from
based on hb2
and it combined the speech pathology
board with the board that had the
audiology and the hearing specialists on
and in the process
we ended up with a board that didn't
specify an audiologist on a board that
oversees audiology
but then when the we had a lengthy
discussion about this bill
and we once again heard about an issue
we had heard before
that had to do with how difficult
it was to hold board meetings because
they couldn't get a quorum
and there was
discussion about
having alternates on the board
so
what i did is this amendment
adds alternates
and it puts it in a place in statute
that enables any board that's under the
allied help
to spec to add
alternates simply by
updating the part of the statute that
describes their board
and because when you're going to have
alternates you have to have a have a
description of them and you have to
identify what it is that they can do and
when they can do it
so that's what that's what the amendment
does
represent march do you wish to speak to
your second
about just that adding alternate let's
meet quorum requirements which is
necessary
very good any comments or questions
representative lekkas
um does this include the uh
all the changes in the original bill
adding the audiologist and the
registered hearing
aide thank you
the answer is yes yes yes the board
definition is actually on page two
any other comments or questions on the
amendment
okay
seeing none the motion is on amendment
number
oh two four four h
thank you
and the clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes
yes clerk votes yes representative
pearson yes
representative yakovich
yes
representative lekkis yes representative
allegro yes
representative bailey yes
representative lonzara yes
representative santo nestaso yes
representative goalie yes representative
shewit
yes
representative judy we miss you
representative marsh yes representative
fellows
yes
represent representative fontenot yes
representative grota yes
representative o'brien
yes and the chair
yes 18-0
representative fellows do you have a
motion
yes um i move ought to pass with the
amendment and i second that
any further discussion on the
motion of ought to pass with amendment
okay
i think we've covered that
in that case the clerk can call the roll
the motion is ought to pass with
amendment
0244h on house bill 1427. representative
rhodes
yes
clerk votes yes representative pearson
representative jacob
yes
representative
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative lanzarra yes
representative santo anastaso yes
representative goalie yes representative
show it yes representative judy we miss
you
representative marsh yes representative
fellows
yes represent representative fontenot
yes
representative grotin yes
representative o'brien yes
and the chair
yes 18 same 18-0 all right
in the spirit of harmony is there any
objection to consent this motion passed
18-0
i'm sorry i have a motion
okay
fine
house bill 1427 will be
on consent and you have a motion on
i apologize um
on amendment 0425 to house bill 1357
and that's amendment number oh two four
five
i think it's oh four two five oh four
two five
thank you that's my mistake
is there a second
second
second seconded by representative goalie
could you say the bill again
house bill 1357
land acknowledgement
this amendment corrects the spelling
in the rich every oh you would like me
to speak did you ask me to speak please
speak to your amendment okay
um this amendment corrects a spelling
that was that was um incorrect in the
original bill and also
um
add a statement that this
acknowledgement is not to be interpreted
as a land claim
okay
um
goalie you seconded no font no do you
wish to speak to your second no a goal
or a scholar i second it oh
do you you wish to speak to the second i
am all set haven't you okay thank you
i emailed it to everyone on the
committee last week what no paper
i know i'm so sorry i was hoping that
people had read their emails if we not i
can get copies of it
um
yeah i noticed it in the email but uh i
apologize i will uh
i'll get a paper copy
uh i think it's simple enough that we
can we can discuss it before we uh
get more paper copies since they aren't
available should we request a short
recess
she just has to go upstairs to get a
copy right
i can i can table i'd like to i'll be
fine we will take a recess and you'll
bring it back after lunch
that's fine thank you thank you
okay representative pearson you have a
motion on house bill 1681
the code update
i believe i do
so there is
should we should we address the
amendment first
yeah i think we should
i'm sorry could you repeat the bill
number 1681 thank you that's your
amendment
do you want so maybe you can see if
there are copies of it here
yep they're on the table
okay thank you very much
okay
so
i'll second your motion thank you
would you wish to speak to your motion i
would there
in the course of the state adopting
um
the next batch of codes if you will as
we as we move forward
this is a
an integral
movement in the sense that you can't
really move
say the electric code and not move the
fire code at the same time or
some of the other codes because they all
reference each other so
you get into you get into all kinds of
problems so when this bill was drafted
just as an absolute oversight the
moving of the fire code up from the 2015
edition to the 2018 edition was
inadvertently left out this amendment
puts that
back where it should have been when
if the bill had been drafted and the
oversight had not occurred
thank you i'd like to mention that when
i was drafting the bill i ran it past
the the
among other people the state fire
marshal and
he i and the
building code review board all
completely blanked on missing the fire
code so i have to apologize for that
that oversight it was in the original
intention when we updated the codes
to update the entire suite
and
it was just an oversight and i hope you
will help me fix it
any other comments or questions
it does include all the amendments
reviewed by the board of fire control
they
incorporated
the amendments
some of them were brought forward from
the
2015 edition they are all available
online
seeing no comments
the motion is to adopt amendment o422h
to house spill 1681 and the clerk can
call the roll
representative rhodes yes
clark verts yes representative pearson
yes representative jakob
yes representative lucas yes
representative allegro yes represent
bailey yes
representative lazzaro yes
representative santo anastasia yes
representative goalie
yes representative schuett yes
representative judy we miss you
representative
marsh
yes representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grote yes
representative o'brien
yes
and the chair
18-0 for adoption of the amendment okay
the motion passes eighteen to zero
president pearson
i move autopsy with amendment on house
bill 1681
any further comments
uh yeah i mean
as this incorporates like i said the
the batch the state of new hampshire
little historic
perspective in honor of representative
schmidt here um
the
when the state adopts that series of
codes we typically do it on a on a
little bit of a delay
and that's been there's a plethora of
reasons for that those reasons have been
expounded upon in testimony
um i'll point out that
we
saw representatives from all of the
various trades
building code review board electrical
guys building officials all those folks
were here
and they're all in favor of this passing
as a block
and as i stated earlier
these codes reference each other so much
that they do have to pass and move
forward as a block so
this um
this will just get the state of new
hampshire moving forward
with its with its coded updates and
allow the builders inspectors and
whatnot to uh
to get on board with the with the
current changes
okay
thank you
i'd like to mention that this was
the recommendation of two separate study
committees on building code updates
one two three years ago and one this
year
that recommend or last year that we
update the building code
regularly
on a schedule that allows us to make all
the amendments necessary to fit new
hampshire conditions
and
this bill includes
all
the not only the 2018 building codes
it includes the amendments adopted by
the building code
review board and the board of fire
control
to take care of things like our ban on
sprinklers and single-family houses
and addresses
our specific
issues
other comments representative black
okay i uh
was torn on this that i mean we're being
asked to approve a whole mass of things
that
we don't actually know what's in it i
understand that these boards have looked
it over
and initially my plan was to vote
against this only because of that
i had asked for details which i finally
did get but very very recently and i did
start looking through them and there is
a lot of material there
so
i don't know whether on net um these
changes are ones that i think are
positive or negative um
there has been time to look at that
um i decided to look at it as
this is you know the approval we're
doing is not approving it in detail
but it's kind of a last chance that if
you know some citizens in new hampshire
others had objections they could come to
us and we could either fix it or put a
stop to it
but i do suggest that in the future if
they're for this sort of thing anything
where we have to we're put in position
of approving or not approving
a large mass of things
that the details be provided well in
advance i'm talking um
you know month or month or months
so that if someone does want to look it
over in some detail there is the time to
do it so i will vote for this this time
but i'm not very comfortable doing so
thank you
thank you yes i'm
i apologize that the details were not
provided earlier because they are
available they were given to the study
committee
in
september or october
so they they
they haven't changed since then at least
but we didn't give them to this
committee
all right any other comments questions
concerns
all right seeing none the motion is
ought to pass with amendment on house
bill
and the clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes
yes the clerk votes yes representative
pearson
representative yakovich yes
representative lucas uncomfortably yes
i'll put a little you next to it here
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative lonzara yes
representative santo nastaso yes
representative goalie yes
representative schuett yes
representative
trudy
lee
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota
yes
representative o'brien yes
representative mcguire
yes
otherwise known as the chair i'm sorry
my name
well yeah but it's not your 18-0
okay the motion
passes ought to pass with amendment 18
to zero is there any objection to
consent
okay seeing none will go with consent
all right that's a note of of unity
medal chair i do have the amendment to
uh house bill 1357 if you'd like me to
pass it around oh let's do that one next
then okay
thank you
resuming the executive session on house
bill 1357
hmm
when i heard the testimony on house bill
1357 we noted that
the spelling was incorrect in the
original bill
and we certainly don't want to go on
record with that
and there was concerns that i heard
about the end game which made me think
of land acknowledgements
and so i was there was a phrase there
was a sentence added
at the end that says this
acknowledgement does not permit any land
grants pursue unto the 1713 treaty of
portsmouth
so i'm merely asking at this time to
pass this amendment to correct the bill
and to add that phrase
thank you was there a second i was just
going to ask a second
representative marsh
seconds i'm so sorry
do you wish to speak to your second uh
yes i'd just like to point out that the
1713 treaty is exceedingly well
documented with existing copies on both
sides of the atlantic and i
having read that treaty i believe it
would
preclude
the expansion of land claims based on
this acknowledgement which i agree could
become an issue so thank you
okay
then why is that last sentence necessary
other comments questions
representative allegro
i think this bill is so overwhelmingly
bad that it doesn't merit an amendment
okay that's concise any other comments
all right seeing none the motion is to
adopt amendment
0425h to house bill 1357
made by representative the clerk can
call the rule
representative rhodes yes
represent the clerk votes yes
representative pearson yes
representative yakubovic
representative lekkis yes representative
allegro
can you guess
well on the amendment
yes
the answer is
on the amendment
representative bailey
yes
representative lonzara
representative santo nastasso
representative goalie
representative show it
just talk loud
too many mics on
representative goalie voted yes
representative show it
representative judy we miss you
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota yes
representative o'brien yes the chair yes
uh 17-1
okay amendment the amendment passes 17
to 1.
representative grow do you have a motion
i do madam chair otpa on house bill 1357
is there a second
second
seconded by representative goalie okay
do you wish to speak to your motion
i do thank you
so when i heard this bill
originally i put it in the ceremonial
category
because
i wasn't concerned about land grants
in that
the business the the tribe would have to
be recognized
by the indian business
the bureau of indian affairs to have a
land grant
and since that takes a lot of money
and usually
involves
a commitment to a casino and the
abernathy penacook indian indians are
not
interested in that
there would be no land claims in new
hampshire with this article with this
amendment i mean sorry with this statue
furthermore i spoke to a former attorney
general of new hampshire
who said that he viewed this
as
a ceremonial
or historical bill and we talked about
it
i know that this committee is not
has not been recognizing ceremonial
bills presented them and
i'm in favor of that
but i thought of i spoke with um
miss puyol this morning
and this bill came about as a result of
the
anniversaries that are happening on the
seacoast for example with my town of rye
is having its 400th anniversary this
year next year i mean
and um
as well as many other seacoast
communities so i asked the committee to
look at this from a historical
perspective in that before we came to
new hampshire and called new hampshire
new hampshire
there was a land and it was called
andachna
it was an occult new hampshire
all we're doing is recognizing that this
land existed before we came and before
we named it
and it's part of our history
thank you
son of goalie do you speak to your
second
i think representative grota
spelt it out very eloquently thank you
okay
representative rhodes thank you madam
chairman
i i think there's been a lot of bills
that we've heard
this
this particular term that start out with
this is a very very simple bill
and it seems to me that the very very
simple bills really scream a lot of
not quite so simple
and the one concern that i have is there
was some testimony given and there was
some very very
specific language that was given and
when there were questions asked onto
exactly what does that mean
everybody kind of scuttled and ran from
the question specifically
what exactly is restorative justice
that
was mentioned
but then nobody wanted to
refer to it that is the one concern
that i have is how simple really is this
may i speak to that please
yes representative
it's unfortunate sometimes that when
bill's bills are heard people who are
not involved with the bill
our public for example will come and
testify
and i believe that is my belief and is
my
sad
um
feeling
that
the people who spoke after mr and mrs
peyote
we're not
i'm sorry it's puyo
we're not um
we're not fair they were not fair to our
committee and they weren't fair to the
people of new hampshire
and i can understand the concerns about
that
i can't allay your concerns
but you have to realize that
not everybody
um
i hope
that
not everybody has the same amount of
fairness
in the meaning of the legislation
or bill
and we take the element the emotional
elements out of it
as opposed to
getting tangled up with
what the public may perceive it to be
does that help you
other comments representative blackis
thank you um
i share a similar concern and i
can understand that that's
not your interpretation of this i
certainly accept that but it points out
the risk that um
you know we can put something in with
one intent
and people can try and use it for other
purposes
and um you know we don't know
i don't know what's going to happen in
the future
what the views of let's say courts or
other people might be in the future and
so i share those concerns
representative allegro
i received a number of emails from
members of other tribes
opposing this this bill appears to be
divisive even amongst native americans
so that's one problem with it
um the other goes along the lines of
what representative rhodes indicated and
so i won't belabor that point
um
perhaps with some
historical uh perspective but i'm not
going to
waste the committee's time with it thank
you
okay other comments
questions concerns
representative scitec
let me waste 20 seconds
ever since the norman's norman french
invaded england might makes right and
this is another example of it this land
acknowledgment is just window dressing
over it
uh an instance in our history of might
makes right
that's all
okay representative fellows i just have
a question about that that preambulation
part because we share a border with
canada so why are we pre-emulating the
borders with the other states and not
that's not
the foreign relation with the other
states is in current statute and i
believe that we're not perambulating the
border with canada because we cannot
affect it that's the international
border too the other one too this is rsa
one this rsa is so old that it there was
no canada it was it was a british empire
that that's that's why they're not
referenced
yes something like that but i really i
think that it's because if there's a
dispute between the
between us and massachusetts we can we
have we know where to fight it out but
we really don't want to go to war with
canada over perambulating the bounds of
pittsburgh
just just a second point is i'm i
received emails about other um
native americans
that
were not are not mentioned here and we
have had previous bills where we know
that there is some
disagreement
about
you know who to recognize as as
indigenous people
in this area so i
have concerns about this bill
thank you other comments
yeah i'm concerned that it seems to be
picking one
one particular tribe and saying you're
you're the only ones that count and i
don't like that at all
representative site they had a better pr
firm
yes thank you we are well aware of that
any other comments concerns issues
all right thank you the motion is ought
to pass with amendment on house bill
1357 and the clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes no
the clerk votes yes representative
pearson no
representative
no
what's going on representative allegro
representative bailey
no
i'm still voting yes
representative lonzaro no
representative santo nestaso no
represent goalie yes
representative schuett
yes
representative judy
we miss you
representative marsh yes
representative fellows
no
representative fontno
yes
representative grota
absolutely
representative of brian
yes
and the chair
now
my word
two four six
eight in favor and a lot against two
four six eight ten
the motion fails eight to nine
i'd like to make another motion
uh
representative first i believe
yes i'd uh like to make a motion of itl
there a second
we're okay
motion is an expanding to legislate by
representative leckus second by
representative rhodes any discussion
well i'll just uh briefly mention that
and we pretty much uh talked about it
there are
concerns about what the effect of the
bill could be in the long term but also
the fact that
there is disagreement among the tribes
as to
this bill i think is a perfectly good
reason to i tell it
representative rhodes do you wish to
speak to your second
no thank you madam chairman
any further discussion or comment
okay not seeing any the motion is
inexpedient to legislate and the clerk
can call the role
representative rhodes
yes
the
clerk votes no
representative pearson yes
representative
yes representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lonzara yes
representative santo nestaso
yes
representative goalie no
representative schuett
no representative judy
not mr
representative marsh no
representative fellows yes
representative fontenot no
representative grota no
representative o'brien
no
and the chair
yes
so it is uh
10 8 the other direction okay motion
passes nine to eight i don't think this
will go on consent madam chair isn't
that ten to eight okay nine
representatives we've had 18 voting all
along
ten eight oh that was nine
my mistake it is in fact 10 8 and the
previous vote was eight nine eight ten
sorry
the
um
as i was saying this doesn't seem to
belong on consent representative groter
you're going to be writing a minority
report yes i will
okay
and representative blackis
yes okay
yeah i'm sure
may i make a motion yes representative
moved to octopass on
one five eight seven
second
who was who's second goalie
we should speak to your motion
yes briefly
uh
the the no investment uh
in the private sector
does this uh it's
basically uh like an income tax um
and i could leave the rest for a debate
i'm sorry madam chair can you please
give me the house bill again
if it's 1587 but i don't understand what
the comment had to do with the bill but
perhaps i don't understand it properly
representative golick
you you seconded could you uh
yes madam chair thank you um
this bill
went to subcommittee and it did come out
a subcommittee with a three to two vote
of ought to pass
um
this bill will allow
all of the years of service
and wages to be used in calculating the
average final compensation for
individuals
currently we heard of
a woman that works in corrections
and
she is
being forced to work overtime due to
staffing shortages
and unfortunately
she's paying money into the retirement
system off of
all of her wages
and
not all of that
is being calculated when she's going
when she comes up for retirement for her
um average final compensation
and that's
a uh
just not right
she's paying and being charged for a
benefit and not receiving the full
benefit she should on those wages
so with that being said i i will support
the ought to pass and
that way these folks can continue to
have their wages counted
okay thank you representative blackis
thank you um
so i have a
i think a question um
my understanding of the reason for this
was that uh
there was concern that
um you know someone could in the last
few years however many years of the time
they're working
make a particular effort to really
significantly increase the amount of
money they're making which would
increase their pension
and then they'd be getting a pension
for the rest of their life that's
based largely on just the last you know
limited period and that the reason for
that it was done this way was to prevent
that so
if
we're not going to
you know if we're going to change this
then these are you know what else should
we do is there's something we should do
to deal with what i believe you know
could be a real problem
representative pearson thank you madam
chair
um
to to
touch upon what representative lekka
said there are multiple multiple
multiple things now in statute that are
that prevent spiking so this this is um
there's no there's no risk here
for some sort of explosion in the
capabilities of spiking there are many
other things that that are also in
statute that kick in
my my issue here
is is
threefold um
the enaction of this back in 2010
actually violated the new hampshire
state constitution in part first article
23 because it was done retroactively
and that should have never occurred and
frankly i'm shocked that none of these
agencies ever filed suit over this under
that under that premise because it was a
clear
clear violation
the other thing too is we as we heard in
testimony here you know we the
department of corrections specifically
as well as as some some of the other
agencies that are concerned law
enforcement and fire
have such massive
staffing problems that you're putting
people into a situation of forced labor
and
you're now putting people into into that
scenario of forced labor you're taking
money out of their paycheck and putting
it into a general corpus it is not
counted towards their retirement well if
you're going to take money out of
someone's paycheck based on their rate
of pay and you're going to put it into a
fund that that does not calculate
a benefit to them you have enacted an
income tax and that's exactly what this
equates to it equates to an income tax
so if we're going to have folks if we're
going to have especially folks that run
on a no income tax pledge
this is exactly an income tax that
happens to
exist for a very very minut
amount of people but it is in fact
an income tax
so
i think the fair thing here is if you're
going to work especially those that are
forced in into working if you're going
to work and monies are going to be drawn
from your paycheck then they should
simply count
no one would
ever get into a private sector
investment where you would give money to
an investment company and then have them
say oh thanks for the last five years of
investments but those don't really count
towards towards what you're doing
no one would enter into that sort of
thing in the private sector there's no
other
system where that occurs it just happens
to occur here
and frankly it is a matter of fairness
it's a matter of equity and and i
do not support income taxes at all and
that's how i view this
thank you
senator fellow
thank you madam chair i'd just um like
to respond to representative lekkis's
last statement and just to suggest if
you look at line 26
on the first page of the bill
it says that
for their
pay for their hours that were beyond the
normal work week
that
the percent
that that can add to their final
compensation is based on the average of
those excess hours over the entire
period that they were
employed
and you're absolutely right that people
used to you know build up those last
three years
but that was partially addressed
i'm not sure how many years ago it was
when they put in you know some
restrictions on that but then this this
shows that it's gonna
they can't spike it in the last three
years they can work extra hours in the
last three years but they're only going
to get credit
for whatever was the average over their
whole career and we know for
particularly for corrections
that they um it's normal for the
corrections office
officers to have a lot of
extra hours
yes and i will mention that when we were
looking at it we found that the vast
bulk of people who worked a lot over
time in their last few years had worked
a lot of overtime throughout their
career
um but
yes
we and we don't quite have the
opportunities for spiking that some
other public pensions do
uh i knew a san francisco firefighter
who i i will not describe his scheme to
boost his pension
representative scitec
yeah i didn't understand a lot of what's
been said
by representative pearson i don't know
that there's a lot of other anti-spiking
stuff all over the statutes i can go
over it if you want
i don't want to thanks
but i don't believe it
i also
the
i don't understand also that people do
get credit toward their pension for this
i don't know that it's capped
i'm willing to be educated on that
but i'm just not accepting these things
one of the statements i heard
was that someone was going to lose
fifteen hundred dollars a month on
account of this on their pension not
the difference was fifteen hundred
dollars a month because of the
anti-spiking
that's
very hard to believe also especially in
light of the fact that these people
whether it's forced labor or not
um
do get compensated for it
this is an anti-spiking not an
anti-pension
provision
it's been around for about 10 years and
it's now on our doorstep
the other and final thing i'm a member
of the retirement system i was a teacher
i got no opportunity no opportunity to
speak of
to spike uh
i mean i would have been like to i
suppose sucked at that banquet but i had
no such opportunity
so some are being favored over others in
the even in our public sector
so i i think this
i want to put aside my dyspepsia here
and say i think there's some room to
consider things here but i'm not
i'm just not comfortable with this
particular bill i'd like to hear more
about it i'd like this to have a genuine
study
and i'll leave
i'll leave my leave that as my remark
representative lakas
thank you um
i guess this is another question so um
it says for purposes of inclusion the
calculation the average percent anyway
it refers to full base rate of
compensation so the question is what is
that i mean if you work overtime is that
part of that or not it is not
okay so is it just your sort of
base salary
correct
okay thank you
other representative fellow
i would just like to say that
the situation in testimony that
representative scitec just mentioned
caught my attention to
i believe she was not referring to
the amount of her retirement paycheck
she was referring to the amount that
would be used in her annual final
compensation
so
you know
you know you understand the difference
here yeah thank you
any other representative blackish yes
another question i mean that brings up
uh i don't know if anybody has the
answer but uh
you know how much of a
difference would this make
in someone's salary if they did
end up working a lot i guess there's a
fiscal note um
so it's talking about
almost 56 million dollars
fy23 i'm not sure
it is well it's limited because
this only applies to people who were
working but not yet vested when the
rules were changed in 2011
right
and correct so it's a limited population
that is involved
and the spread from three to five years
um
from exactly
the change from
five years to three years means it's
more likely that any
promotions that you get would be
reflected in your pension because it's
an average
that your final pay
okay thank you i'm slightly confused on
your explanation with the three years
the three years was done away within
there is no more three years
i mean i get confused with all these
bills too sorry i'll take that away
the the intent is i believe that
to allow the even if you get a promotion
to have the same
percentage of overtime and extra duty
etc that you did throughout your career
is that correct
typically folks you know as your command
staff works their way up sure you know
you you typically have folks with a lot
of experience
being in charge towards the end
but as you know as far as some of the
anti-spiking provisions just to give
just not even no details just topics we
have a pension cap as far as the maximum
pension
we have the 150 percent rule we have the
um
average of compensation based over your
entire career those are all anti-spiking
provisions so there's many anti-spiking
provisions that are in statute
that prevent those things from occurring
this one
just became it's too much of a penalty
is is the problem with this it's you
know we in there were so many things
enacted so fast that they never really
gave time to vet
the efficiency of those things
and this one is problematic the the
other
particular ones i am totally in
agreement with it's just this one is the
problem
representative if you could uh a brief
explanation on the 150 one you mentioned
sure the 150 rule has to do with you
you cannot
you cannot earn more than 150
of what you earned the prior year when
you go to retire
and that prevents someone from in their
last year let's say
working an exorbitant amount of
of time to try to boost that and that
150 percent rule was enacted to prevent
abuse that had occurred in the past and
it i mean that's absolutely worked
okay thank you
other comments or questions
representing scitec
i noticed mr carlin here and i'd like to
take the opportunity advantage to ask
how's that chart doing
how's that chart doing remember when we
were going through representative
mcguire talked about vested and that
opened the door to i die when i'm vested
i'm not that i you know get hit by a
truck when i'm you know
what are my survivor benefits you're
going to change it from paragraph form
to a flip chart for us
okay thank you we we do need that
because
as you notice from the debate it's easy
for us to get confused over what this
bill does versus what other previous
bills would have done
yes representative i might say to
representative pearson that you've got
me thinking but i'm not sure just how
much anti
uh i got
i'm not persuaded yet
although you've made
i didn't cover all of them that was like
three of the many another time
okay thank you is there any other
comments questions discussion
okay
the motion is ought to pass on house
bill 1587 the clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes
no
plug parts no representative pearson yes
representative yakovich
yes
representative lekkis no
representative allegro yes
represent bailey no
representative ludzara yes
represent santo nestaso no
representative goalie
yes representative schuett
yes representative judy we miss you
representative marsh yes
representative fellows
yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota
yes representative o'brien
yes and the chair
now
12 to 6.
okay the motion passes 12 to 6
it will not be on consent this
madam chair i believe it's 14 to 6 that
adds to 18 does it 12 to 16 to 18.
i was going to stop anyway yes
representative now you know what it
feels like
that'll be on the regular calendar
[Music]
goalie
okay i think that's all we should do
before lunch we
it's 12 15
we will come back at
1 45 and i'd like to see the republicans
back here
by
by one o'clock so we could caucus
i'm back
145.
all right
[Music]
we'll start with house bill 1288
which it to which representative fellows
is passing around
an amended amendment
yes
i had presented amendment 002
as as a non-jermaine amendment this is a
slight tweak to that amendment
so
representative fellowes moves amendment
0522h
certainly i second
okay thank you
so um this is the bill
that
um
one of the main features of the bill is
is that it renamed
a division
within the department of administrative
services
and it's a division that does i t kind
of work
and
they the original bill
proposes a name for the um
division of enterprise
operations
managed management i think i don't have
a copy right in front of me and i was
concerned about that title because
i think i was thinking that you know
people
general public isn't going to understand
what enterprises
and i was also concerned with enterprise
operations
would
in my mind it would be referring to all
of the executive branch
so what i did is i reached out to
dennis goulet
who is the commissioner of oit
and who oversees i.t related things for
the whole state
and also
alexander
i believe his name is alexander
stone
who is
the
administrator of this division
that is proposed to be renamed
and i told them my concerns about the
title i said i really didn't have
have a problem with the description
and i asked them if they could each of
them if they could think of a better
title well what they did is they got
together and they reworked
that section of the bill
and they did change the title
they also
changed
on page one you can see there's a roman
numeral
one two three and four
about five six
that describes what that division does
they did rework that some
also
and the email that i got back from
the commissioner of oit
was that that was
necessary
because
[Music]
the original wording
seemed to imply
that that division
would have domain over some things that
are clearly
the domain of oit so
what you're looking at is
in that section two
is
not my words but what
that division director
and the commissioner of oit came up with
and then the only other thing that is
different
between this and
chairman mcguire's
amendment is that
on the second page
on paid on line six
or line five
they just had to change that title
because
that's the director of and i had they
had to use the new name there
other other than that it's exactly um
like representative mcguire's bill
hey representative schuett you used to
wish to speak to your second
uh
i apologize i thought i heard your voice
who did seconded
grota okay representative grota do you
wish to speak to your second
no thank you okay
no problem i should have just said no
art
i was astonished when i was filling in
on another committee and
for
i don't know about a dozen bills they
said you wish to speak to your motion
and they say no thank you
and so
we no votes
i was shocked
anyway i'd like to comment on this this
is
in essence the bill that i put in the
amendment that i put in at the behest of
administrative services it's acceptable
to the
to the people involved which is the most
important thing for a job title
and
it clarifies their duties so
any other comments questions
representative pearson i just think it's
interesting that we went from amendment
number two to amendment number 522 that
shows you how much
work the house of representative has to
do
to to work on legislation well i had
that amendment as soon as i
was able to as i knew the bill was
coming to this committee so
any other comments
okay seeing none the motion is
on amendment
0522h to house bill 1288 and the clerk
can call the role
rhodes
yes
clark votes yes representative
pearson
yes
representative yakubovic yes
representative
yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes
representative zara yes
represent representative santo destasso
yes
representative goalie
representative schuett yes
representative judy
we miss you
representative marsh yes
representative um
fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grote
yes please
representative o'brien yes and the chair
yes
18 to 0. okay the motion passes 18 to 0.
uh representative hellos do you have an
amount do you have another motion
this is representative fellows and i
make a motion ought to pass for house
bill
with amendment number zero five two two
h
all second
any
do you wish to speak to your motion
um i think that
this
amendment is important because it brings
up to date what is happening in a
division within administrative services
and that's a division that has
a very significant role
you can see read what they do on page
one
and
it
representative mcguire would you like to
speak to the two other parts
i'll yes thank you i'll uh the original
bill addressed the fact that when we
created those unclassified positions
we didn't we give them a specific term
so they had an indefinite term which is
generally not recommended so the first
part of the bill simply gives them a
four-year term
which is
as a common one in the executive branch
the
training fund
upped
being allowed to increase to 100 000 is
partly
before it
lapses to the general fund is partly due
to
inflation of course and more people
getting training courses
it's also a factor of the fact
factor that many of the courses are done
in the summer
so
you want to be able to have the money to
pay for them and not have it lapse just
because the budget expires at the end of
the end of june
and because of that bill is going to go
to finance for that to take to look at
the dedicated fund
other than that um
let's i support it
any other comments or questions
crickets okay thank you
that case the motion is ought to pass
with amendment on house bill 1288 and
the clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes
yes
clerk votes yes representative pearson
yes representative yakovich
yes representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative on zara yes
representative
yes
representative goalie yes
representative schuett
yes
representative judy we miss you
representative fellows
yes representative marsh yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota yes representative
o'brien yes
and the chair
yes
okay the motion passes 18 to zero is
there any objection to consent
all right seeing none we'll put it on
consent
all right
uh house bill 1429 licensing massage
establishments represent pearson you
have a motion
probably
let's see
let me find it
there we go
i'm going to make a motion on health
bill 14 9 excuse me 1429 for interim
study hi second
thank you
do we should speak to your motion
i do madam chair thank you
this um
this is a new this is an important bill
to me actually
we have
my my community of dairy has some some
very serious concerns
uh in reference to
[Music]
enforcement of
many things surrounding these
establishments and
and i think that this bill
doesn't
doesn't quite give the local
enabling that that i think would be more
necessary and more effective here than
having this come out of the office of
oplc
so you know this i
don't don't look at this as death with
dignity here i really do think that we
need to
to look at this and find a way to make
this work
for those communities that do in fact
have concerns
um surrounding
massage establishments and
not really burden
a state agency
where the overwhelming majority of the
state
does not deal with this
this type of place
represent baroda
thank you madam chair
we receive
letters from many communities
in southern new hampshire that see a
need for this kind of legislation
but i will
support
the interim study bill so that we can
get the look the municipality issue
resolved
in a
more
in a way that um
is satisfactory to the committee
other comments questions
represent
part of that resolution is uh it became
clear in the discussion it's not
it isn't clear that the towns
municipalities
are authorized to do this
and that ought to be
that's got to be part of what's
addressed
yeah we we did get some comments from
other municipalities
but the the thrust was from derry and
all the other municipalities were in the
southeast corner of the state
so
imposing a statewide registration
for a
seacoast
and massachusetts border problem seemed
excessive
i'd just like to point out there's
nothing really wrong with the southeast
corner of the state
i concur
excellent we have bipartisan agreement
on that
any other comments questions
all right seeing none the motion is
interim study on house bill 1429
i was waiting for my cue
representative rhodes
yes
the clerk votes yes representative
pearson yes representative jacob
yes representative lekkis yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes
representative lanzara yes
representative santana
yes
representative goalie
representative schwart
yes
representative judy we miss you
representative marsh
yes
representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota
yes
representative o'brien
and the chair
yes it is 18 to 0.
is there any objection to consent
the vote was eighteen to zero
okay seeing none we'll put that on
consent
all right
mr tori
is is the amendment for 1535 back yet
there what
no oos
okay then that's
in that case we'll take up the last
early bill that doesn't need an
amendment which is house bill 1417
and representative rhodes you have a
motion
yes madam chair
i would like to move itl on house bill
is there a second
representative like a second
okay would you speak to your motion
yes i would thank you
the towns in new hampshire have full
authority on how many employees they
would like to hire and to what they
would like to pay all of those employees
if the state is going to be contributing
to to this portion um i think that it
would only also be fair that the state
had the responsibility
of actually hiring the employees and
also helping to set the rate
and i also think that despite the fact
that the
verbiage that we've been hearing a lot
of
all of the downshifting to the towns
from 2011 that was actually
shifted down to the responsibility of
the employees
thank you representative lackas
thank you um
i agree with that and and actually i
remember i think it was in 2020 our
delegation for our district got
kind of called on the carpet before the
uh
boards of selectmen of of hudson and
pelham on this issue
and uh you know we expressed the same
thing we asked them so if you want us to
help pay for it
uh would you be okay with us uh
you know controlling the number of
employees you can hire and putting some
limitations on the pay
they did not find that attractive and uh
but i think it would only be reasonable
otherwise we're in effect
you know providing an unlimited
potentially amount of money so thank you
hey representative o'brien had a comment
i believe
yes
thank you madam chair thank you uh
the reason i arise is because i strongly
disagree i think there's some
basically what people believe is true
but it may not actually be 100 percent
factual
uh in case some of you who do not know i
wear two hats
i am also a state representative but i'm
also vice president of the board of
aldermen for the good citizens for the
city of nashua
the citizens of nashua the uh board of
aldermen in the mayor wants this
particular bill i don't want to get into
too much of the past history and drain
that two down as i explained it but
the pension system was formed in 1968
with the state paying 35 percent that
has been morphed down to zero
that 35 percent where did it go it
didn't vaporize okay it got thrown back
on to the employees it also got thrown
back on to the municipality
now i hear there's limitations
well
i'm not here i was a firefighter i'm not
here to give you a math lesson
but when you come to a pension system it
doesn't matter what you pay
your your employees has nothing to do
with it at all
it's based on the lara percentages
if uh somebody is making one dollar an
hour would they put as much into the
pension system as somebody who's making
two dollars an hour no
if they're paying a certain percentage
the person that pays that's getting the
higher rate goes in
so therefore it's not really affecting
an hrs
when it comes down to it it has to do
with the laws of percentages nothing to
do what firefighters cops or teachers
are being paid
a lot of things have happened besides
this as well
the ull
that is now currently be faced by many
cities and towns
in order to get back and i strongly
encourage that i would like to see a
pension system that is 100 percent
funded and ready to go
but right now your tax payers need a
break
whether you have one cop in your town
or
200 such as the city of nashua does or
any teachers one teacher or 200 teachers
they're paying into the nhrs system
nashua is paying
million dollars a year fathom that
because of nhrs obligations
four million dollars it only takes two
million dollars to raise the tax rate in
the city of nashville one percent
this is a two percent tax rate all this
bill is saying
it's asking to state what they
originally started in 1968
to step forward
honor their original obligations and pay
not thirty
or thirty five percent
but basically come up and only pay per
employee seven five per seven point five
percent
where will that money go you'll be
thanked by your taxpayers thank you
madam chair
thank you does it representative growth
and then like us
thank you um
when the new hampshire retirement system
was
initiated
it was
initiated by the state
and municipalities were asked to join
municipality employees were asked to
join
the state's
enticement let's say
for getting the municipalities to join
the new hampshire retirement system
was that the state would pay
35 percent of the contributions
of the retirement system
that municipalities would have
to pay
employee employee amounts
paid
is not affected by
where
the government's
contribution comes from whether it be
from the state or from municipalities
now
the state has you know has good times
and bad times and
one of the decisions to reduce the
amount of the state would have to pay
had to do with the difficult times that
the state was
having in revenues
and
i'm not opposed of
of
having obligations from states
municipalities necessarily changed but
i do think that
a permanent
shift from the state to the municipal to
the municipalities for their portion of
the retirement system
is unfair
and it's unfair the people
who
and example of those municipalities who
entered into this agreement in good
faith
and now
their good faith is being taken
advantage of
so i support this um
bill
and
i support what representative o'brien
says
thank you
hey representative blackis thank you um
i'm certainly sympathetic to the
taxpayers
you know having to pay
what they're paying
to make up for the ual i'm one of them
and i would also support something like
requiring that some percentage of any
surplus the state has going to pay off
the ual which would then
directly help the taxpayers
um
i'm not supporting this because
it it's you know if we're paying 77 if
we are to pay seven and a half percent
of the contributions then yes that is
entirely dependent on the number of
employees in the and the pay of those
employees so there is a direct relation
between what the state's gonna have to
pay
and what the municipalities choose to do
around hiring and compensation
and i have a concern about that
the other thing is as i understand the
history
at the time i guess 2011
when the state stopped paying the 35
percent
that amount of money in its entirety
uh was
shifted to the employees none of it to
the municipalities now at the same time
there were changes in
actuarial assumptions uh assumptions
around
demography and other things which did
substantially increase the amount that
the municipalities had to pay
but that that increase was not due to
the states
stopping to pay the 35 percent at least
that's
my understanding of the history which
does matter so thank you
very much thank you madam chair
one of the things there's two things
here
with this um
the first one is i would have this was
this would really have
been a better argument when we were
creating the budget
that's the first one the second one
is that
because of the way
because we're using a timed based
a duration based method of paying off
the unfunded liability
this bill does not accelerate the payoff
in any way
and because of that it contributes
to the tremendous rollercoaster effect
that municipalities are experiencing
every two years when the rate changes
i would
be more than happy to get on board with
a seven and a half percent contribution
provided that went into paying and
accelerating the debt
and getting rid of the debt rather than
just
changing the
the employer rate or you know that
i i just
continuing to go down that road like
that it doesn't really do anything to
speed this problem
up
and get rid of it so
i i just i agree with representative
leckas i think the focus really
needs with with the amount the money's
involved here needs to involve the
acceleration of the payoff of debt
and not just the
the
minuscule relief that this may provide
to some municipalities
represent goalie
thank you madam chair
first i'll say that representative lucas
if you want to put the bill in that a
percentage of any surplus we get in the
state go to paying the unfunded
liability put me down as a co-sponsor
i'd be happy to
but as this goes
this bill here is
direct property tax relief
i think anyone out there who talks to
any of
their whether it's a alderman
town council whoever you talk to
will tell you we will take this this is
direct property tax relief from the
state of new hampshire
state that's running a
huge surplus right now
has plenty of money out there to help
cities and towns
this is what they're asking for
i don't think there's one person out
there if you ask them if the state would
save send some of this money back to
them
they would say no we don't want it
so i'm going to support this
i'm going to support the people in my
community that are asking for this
and i'll be voting against the
unexpedient the legislate
okay
thank you goalie any other comments
representative fellows
i i would just like to echo what
representative goalie just said you know
particularly my town at plymouth is they
just really need some help with property
tax relief
anyone else
representative allegra
if i were the municipality that had a
huge deficit i would be saying send the
money too
but
i have to represent the people of
campton
and
i have to encourage campton to be
fiscally responsible
and i i can't see my way clear
to saying that
other municipalities and and this goes
hand in hand with representative lexis
statements
uh that have a free hand to hire as many
people as they want
and pay them whatever they want
i mean if you look at the school budgets
it's just obscene
there are more paraeducators and
god only knows what then there are
teachers
and i can't see telling
my constituents in campton
that they're going to need to be paying
for the overruns in retirement systems
and other municipalities so i can't
support
that concept
point of order minimum chair
i don't think it is appropriate for us
as committee members to make comments on
how other people run their towns and
whether or not they're fiscally
responsible
thank you
that's not a point of order first of all
but
it is a con comment yes and i would have
to agree that
it may not be polite but it is
absolutely true that there are towns
that spend a whole lot more than other
similar towns
for one reason or another
in fact i will comment that in my town
the the town management is frugal and
efficient and the school board is not
so i understand what representative
allegro's comment is that you can see
the difference in attitude between the
two boards
and i'm sure you've experienced
similar things by looking at other towns
in your own i have but just because
towns treat their budgets differently
doesn't make them fiscally irresponsible
that i believe is a matter of opinion
and we are entitled to our opinions at
this point as long as they are expressed
respectfully and politely your your
opinion
you can express your opinion here
representative scitec and then lekis
i see other worthy members i'm not going
to disagree with representative goalie
but i'll point out two things first this
has been in effect for a long time i'm
not sure why it's suddenly today this
session has become as urgent as it seems
to be
and you may answer that i suppose the
second thing is this
this goes to human nature if i told you
tomorrow our tax rate the local property
tax rate was halved
a week later people would still say it's
too much
it's just life
laccas thank you um
another reason why i would prefer uh
helping pay off the ual through some
portion of any surplus rather than this
is that
um this is a fixed amount and it's going
to be that fixed amount unless the
statutes change regardless of
the economic situation and the financial
situation of the state
and i you know i don't want to
to have
you know more built-in spending at the
state level to increase pressure for for
other things um whereas if it's done as
a
a part of a surplus then when times are
good and we have the extra money
we can help out by paying it down but
it's not something that has to happen
every year thank you
representative marsh yes thank you madam
chair as long as we're going to talk
about towns being fiscally prudent i'm
very proud of my town my town has never
approved a bond issue ever i can say
that because i'm the moderator i think
we run a remarkably uh prudent town we
have we don't have fire we don't have
police
it's it's it's a very small place and
yet our tax rate is twice what it is
just a hundred yards down the road in
the town of wolfeboro mostly because
they have lakefront and we don't
i don't represent the town of wolfeboro
the towns that i represent very much
want to see property tax relief and
therefore i will be voting against the
itl motion
thank you representative o'brien
thank you
i just would like to say that
we talked about
representative lakers said like this is
a fixed amount
i don't think this is a building block
to get back to the 35 percent i don't
take it as that but it will be on the
books for a while but look what it will
do again this is a tax payer friendly
bill
okay now
you say fiscally conscious
municipalities are
i got a whole
you know 100 000 people in nashua that
could disagree with you they might say
we're doing a great job a mediocre job
or something like that but they have an
opinion you know why they have an
opinion
because we as city fathers are doing our
job now how do you become fiscally
conscious on a matter of the subject
we're talking about it's called the
unions
the unions come up and they ask for
certain type of wages
that is negotiation
which is sanctioned by this state
there's no commitment that any
municipality has to pay anything
but basically they listen to the unions
and try to come up with a fair and
equitable wage to all
now it was brought up in the past
we need more firemen we need more cops
we need more good qualified teachers and
nashua does
nashua is a large city i wish i lived in
your little towns
but i don't i chose
as part of my career to defend and to
protect
the city of nashua yes i had people
bleed on me throw up on me and other
type of
bodily fluids all over the place that
you may not have in your own little type
of communities and god bless you
but when nashua goes to look to hire
particular people to take these type of
occupations you got to give them
something that they're going to see the
chances of going to a fire
and nashua or greater than maybe in your
own community i'm sure
my brother
representative goalie would say the same
thing about manchester
so therefore this is part of the
conversation so it has really nothing to
do
cities are fiscally conscious when they
negotiate the union contract
again do not compare this to the ull
that's a separate subject matter
all this basically does what
municipalities have to pay
to make up the loss of the 35 percent
nothing to do with the ull
it's the loss of the 35 percent this
just puts a little piece back into the
mix
to come up to help out the taxpayers
because the ull
already made a fiscal impact to nashua
this will help relieve it a little bit
and i think in some of our
local communities and
that is your job now
to help out those communities and to be
fiscally prudent i hope you join with me
and not supporting the otp
and stand with me when i come back with
an alternative motion
upon the defeat of the otp thank you
believe you mean defeat of the itl
defeated the itl and i stand correct and
i thank the chief that's quite all right
i wouldn't want people to think you're
advocating to kill the bill when
uh madam chair of irish i can argue both
sides of the equation
likewise
okay any other comments representative
allegra i'm not going to belabor this
i'm not sure what bleeding and throwing
up has to do with any of this but for
the record i've had plenty of people
bleed and throw up all over me and have
yanked a couple or a few out of the
wreckage and uh out of the water myself
that aside
spending yourself into millions and
millions of dollars in debt
is the very definition of fiscal
irresponsibility and if that offends
anyone i'm very sorry but the truth
shouldn't defend anyone
thank you are there any other comments
particularly preferably related to the
bill
as i will have to agree with
representative pearson that this doesn't
change
anything for the retirement system it
merely
changes a little bit who pays
okay other comments
seeing none
everybody's here okay in that case the
motion is itl on house bill 1417 and the
clerk can call the role
representative rhodes
yes
clerk votes yes
representative pearson yes
representative
yes representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative lanzarra
yes
representative santo nestaso yes
representative goalie
no
representative schuett
representative judy no mr
representative marsh no
representative fellows no representative
font no no
representative grota
no
representative o'brien
no and the chair
yes
okay looks like
10 to eight
the motion passes 10 to 8.
i don't think this should be on consent
uh
will someone be writing a minority
report oh i'll volunteer for this one
okay thank you representative o'brien we
will
make a note of your that you will do
that
sometime tonight please
yes yes
okay
there are still three early bills left
house bill 1535 has an amendment that's
not here yet
and the other two we can't do today
so among the non-early bills we have
represent representative santanastasso
you have a motion on house bill 1065.
uh yes ma'am jared like to make a motion
and expedient to legislate
uh for house bill
there a second
representative bailey second
should speak to your motion
uh yes ma'am chair uh
so this uh
bill
adds licensure rules for uh art
therapists
um
it seems to be that the motivation for
this bill was
to be able to file insurance claims uh
because they
they use they piggyback off the license
system
um and the reason why i'd like to be
initially and to legislate this is
because
the
the reason we do licensing is for uh you
know uh health and safety safety of the
public
and to go ahead and start
making a licensing to
facilitate insurance
billing would actually undermine the
narrative of why we do licensing in the
first place
in addition to that there was actually
no art therapists
that testified in support of the bill so
i don't actually see it as a
problem
okay representative bailey do you wish
to speak to your second no thank you
all right other comments representative
marsh
yes thank you madam chair i'm afraid i
can't support this motion i believe the
alternative motion not to be ought to
pass with the amendment i just passed
out
the reason being that there are many
areas of health care where licensing is
used particularly for insurance purposes
and i see no reason why art therapy
should be any different
we clearly have a shortage of mental
health providers and and we hear
testimony about the art therapists are
going to be useful in that regard
the amendment
merely changes the word board to office
of professional license insurance
certification on page 2 line 22 which
was a request of oplc when they
testified
thank you we can't really discuss the
amendment until the itl motion has been
defeated but thank you for
updating the language
representative scitec
uh
that sounded like
uh my uh
parliamentary inquiry last time look
we're being forced into a position
representative marsh rather glibly
said that we just accept this business
that we're going to license for the sake
of insurance reimbursement why don't we
face the issue and figure out some
honest way
to provide for this rather than going
through this business there is no issue
you can't tell me with a straight face
that there is an issue of public health
and safety involved with art music uh
therapist that kind of thing they're
useful people i'm not descri i'm not
denying that and they should be paid for
their services but it's not a threat
we're public health we're about public
health and safety and i really i don't
have the imagination to figure it out
but there should be some way to
talk to the insurance companies or
commerce committee to figure out how
this can be done in a straightforward
way rather than this pretend
way and that's all
representative
thank you much of what i was going to
say was just covered by representative
scitec the only thing i would add is
that
i'd like to encourage the commerce
committee to look into the possibility
of
having the insurance companies okay
payment based on you know maybe some
national certification
rather than um
forcing them to go through licensure
which really isn't intended for that
purpose thank you
representative fellow
um i believe we heard in testimony that
a year or so ago
the definition of
what is an art therapist was
was updated
and that
you know i don't have it in front of me
but that definition requires a master's
degree at least and we're so we're not
talking about
something that's you know we're not
talking about art teachers we're not
talking about people that
that just do
fun recreational activities we're
talking about people who do things like
help veterans that have ptsd
and helping children who have been
exposed to trauma in their life
and they're in are indeed ways that you
could make that situation worse if you
did not know what you were doing
and many other states licensed art
therapists
it it in some states it falls under the
therapy
category
so i mean maybe representative marsh
knows more the like details of the
medical thing that i do but this is not
just
you know this is an important
occupation
that helps people
that need
mental help so
i just think i think
getting into the insurance issue is
really off track i i really don't even
think we belong there i think we're
we need to be looking at it from the
perspective of
um if people are going to do this are
they qualified in a way that they will
help people and do no harm i think that
that is the main point of
what licensure is about thank you thank
you a couple of years ago
as you mentioned we did discuss art
therapy
and we protected the name
such that only a person who has the
appropriate
education and is certified by their
national professional organization can
call themselves an art therapist
that's the current current law
and
the other issue of course
is that the various types of mental
health counselors
social workers and mental health
counselors in particular are so
exclusive that they won't consider
an art therapist as a
mental health counselor unless they also
get a mental health counselor degree
which
i think is
excessive if we could
get a
broader mental health
professional
license
then that would solve the problem of
every little specific slice
trying to come in and get their own
board and their own
their own statute
and i i think that that would be more
useful than trying to
license as i said every
little
sub-specialty
the doctors managed to do it
you know
a cardiologist and a dermatologist are
both
licensed under the board of medicine but
the board of mental health practice
doesn't do that
and that's my my speech on the issue
uh any other comments questions
representative
seif this is not in order but i'll try
to make it brief
i'll mention this in terms of something
else we're all my feeling is we're over
licensed
and the ice the professions i would like
to de-license
are the ones who have voted with their
feet that can't even make a quorum
is licensing that important that they
can't even show up for their meetings
and
i'm a fan of certification i'm not going
to deny i'm looking at you but i'm not
i'm just talking out loud you know you
made a good point about the people do
good things but
public health and safety licensure it's
anyone else want to vent representative
marsh uh yes i would just like to point
out that the way this bill works is that
the licensed art therapists are going to
be licensed by the board of mental
health practice
with a bunch of other people who are
doing similar things and working on
mental health uh in their various
modalities and that is not dissimilar
from the fact that the board of medicine
uh licenses multiple categories of
medicine so i think there's a lot more
similarity in this bill than uh would be
we would be led to believe listening to
what we just heard
thank you for that information
any other comments
all right looks like everybody's said
enough
the motion is itl on house bill 1065 and
the clerk can call the roll
yes
representative rose has voted yes the
clerk votes yes representative pearson
yes
representative yakovich yes
representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative lanzaro
yes representation
yes
representative goalie
no
representative show it
no representative judy not mr
representative marsh
no representative fellows no
representative font now no no
representative grota
no representative o'brien no and the
chair
yes
thank you representative marsh we will
have a minority report this will be on
the regular
calendar 10 8
i'm sorry i should have said that thank
you for asking
and now for something completely
different representative rhodes you have
a motion on house bill 1321
yes madam chair thank you i i would like
to move that we
find house bill 1321 in expedient to
legislate
is there a second this is the bill we
heard i'll second that okay
representative pearson jumped in first
all right representative roger we should
speak to you
yes thank you madam chair
i'm actually still a little bit puzzled
on exactly what the representative was
attempting to relay to us this morning
of what this bill actually addresses
especially considering that there have
been a few other bills that have already
been passed
that concern the governor's
authority on
emergency powers
and
other than that i
think that's all i have to say
okay representative peterson thank you
madam chair i
i'll echo um
the words of my colleague here that i am
still not sure what the presenter was
trying to accomplish here
considering he filed two two bills that
were almost identical
i do have concerns um
simply about some of the language that
struck out in this
especially you know the the early part
line seven eight nine i mean just just
the fact that you would not
want
the governor to be notifying the other
branches
i mean this is a
this is something where the separation
of powers really needs to come together
on something of a critical nature
that would
require a state of emergency that i i
don't
i don't even understand the logic in
that so
so this is um
considering all the other things that
we've looked at in reference to this i
think this thing here is just is
tremendously ill-advised
representative
thank you i have a number of problems
with this but
the biggest single item was it removes
the legislature's power to end
individual states of emergency
and that's something i know that we on
this committee well back in
house bill uh
514 i think 517 417 sorry was being
dealt with
was something we agreed on and and he
seemed to imply that
you know
we can end the state of emergency
therefore that can be used as a
negotiating item to convince the
governor not to do certain um
emergency orders um a couple problems
with that one is he's eliminating the
requirement that the governor notify the
legislature he's going to do the
emergency orders in advance anyway
and the other thing is you know we had
that situation
in the recent state of emergency there
were
a number of emergency orders that
were widely concerning
among the people and the legislature
but there was a feeling that there was a
need for some of the emergency orders
given the situation
and so
we were
unwilling to use the the the big
you know
non-uh non-uh a very wide broad hammer
basically of ending the entire state of
emergency and therefore there really
wasn't anything we could do about it
and um
you know the points about there being
other bills on this and that's all true
but that that i think is a tremendous
problem with this uh bill thank you
thank you anyone else
yes president
so
i'm going to vote for this bill and in
support of
i'm going to vote against the ito
and the reason is the same reason i
voted
against the original bill last year that
put this these words into statute and
that has to do with the fact that
the original statue in in a way what
this returns to
lets the house and the senate have a
concurrent resolution whenever they
decide to have one to end a state of
emergency
rather than making
that the two bodies get together every
90 days that was my main concern i do
agree though that if this were to pass
that
i would like to see
emergency orders in there also so that
the
two bodies could address
a state of emergency in a specific or a
specific emergency order
thank you anyone else
well not then i'll but in that i think
that eliminating the specific emergency
order is an issue
i'm also severely bothered by in section
two
we amended his previous bill
and he didn't
recognize that change and incorporated
it in this bill
not even bringing us an amendment he
said we'll have to fix it and i don't
think what else there is in this bill is
worth fixing
okay anyone else have a comment question
yes representative
what is the difference
then the previous bill and this one
please
1037 which is the previous bill is
essentially the section two
but we amended it to
leave in the transparency comment
if the first the first section of this
bill is new
so madam chair would you um would you be
willing to elaborate just a little bit
as to what happens if both of these
bills were to go through
ah that would depend on
luck
because whichever bill is passed second
essentially overwrites the previous
spill
so
if we were to pass both of these
we would be relying on luck
to
see which of those two
paragraphs actually applied
yes
all right any other comments or
questions
all right seeing none the motion is
inexpedient to legislate on house bill
1321 and the clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes
yes
clark votes yes
representative pearson yes
representative yakubovic
yes
representative
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes
representative lunzara yes
represent representative santo nestaso
yes
representative goalie
representative show it
yes
representative judy who eat mr
representative marsh yes
representative fellows no
rep representative fontenot
yes
representative grota
representative o'brien
yes
and the chair
do you object to consent nope all right
in that case we will put this on consent
sally
i asked her already she says she does
not object
now you know how it feels now you know
how it feels
all right
i must say thank you all for uh working
so hard today
we have three bills that we will do
tomorrow
starting aft at the public hearing for
the non-germain amendment to house bill
that hearing is at three
we do have other hearings scheduled
during the day which is why that hearing
is at three instead of say 10 30.
at that point we have we need to exact
house bill 1444 which has a subcommittee
first thing in the morning house bill
and house bill 1535
assuming we get that amendment back
all right so
i don't think we'll have time
right yeah not when we're dealing with
the cosmetologists but to finish off
today we have one last bill that didn't
need to go to subcommittee
that um
i don't care how the vote goes does
anyone have a motion on house bill 1460
deleting the age
requirements representative laccas thank
you
i move ought to pass on this
is there a second
i'll second
representative bailey
1460 removing the age requirements for
licensing
do you wish to speak to your motion
representative
i see this i i'm going to use the dread
words but i see this in a sense actually
is just a cleanup bill there are
a variety of ages
through the licensing statutes
some 18 some 21 i think there's one
that's 17.
and
there are other constraints on
the age at which somebody can go into
any of these things i mean a lot of
these have a
an education or certification
requirement
which
impose a practical
age restriction there's um
you know some of them you're going to be
either
being employed by someone or setting up
your own business which you
can't practically do generally if you're
under 18
um
and there's certainly other constraints
so i just see putting the ages in here
as duplicative
um probably the strongest argument that
representative um
provided was and it's not a common thing
but there is the issue of
people who are emancipated they're
basically under 18 but they are
supporting themselves and living
basically as an adult
and
i don't think we should have a licensing
statute of prohibition against them
working although
it you know they're probably not going
to be able to do many if any of these uh
these things at that age i just it's
partly removing uh duplication there's
no need for it in here thank you
okay representative bailey do you wish
to speak to your second no he doesn't
okay does anyone wish to speak
representative pearson and then martian
thank you i i will be voting against the
ought to pass on this for a couple of
reasons um the primary one being
that as as we learned from the sponsor
they're
these folks are still minors and there
is
some serious concerns as to what happens
if in the course of their practicing
there are
legal issues lawsuits
and and the like when it comes to having
someone who's a minor that that's a
that's something that i don't think was
cleared up and i i think just leads to
some problems the other major part i
have on this is in part seven when it
specifically talks about age and
bodywork therapists and we know there is
a long history of abuse and trafficking
that surrounds that that industry
so the last thing i want to do is
provide an avenue for someone who's
already a minor
to be involved in something that
that now becomes permissible under that
form of
business
so i i just think this is a problem in
search of a solution
i take that back this is a solution in
search of a problem
and uh and i i just i i don't think that
this is necessary at all
representative marsh
thank you madam chairman first of all
i'd like to reiterate what
representative pearson says i i agree
with him that
we don't need to be encouraging
the trafficking of minors for illicit
activities in the state of new hampshire
second of all i will point out that the
word occupation is very closely related
to work
okay we issue occupational licenses so
that people can work
we currently have on the books
rsa276a which is the child labor law as
long as that remains in effect i believe
that this bill would be inexpedient to
legislate
because it basically would put our
licensure
requirements in conflict with the child
labor law
so i cannot
support and not to pass and believe this
bill ought to be itl
thank you representative o'brien and
then
thank you man i'm sure i couldn't agree
more with
representative march i am not going to
support the otp i am very concerned
about the youth i mean i'm not going to
get into you know
here we put an age requirement on
smoking
but we're going to allow them to get a
license to go out and do your plumbing
or to fix your hair or to do something
like that and i had too i mean one
glowing group that was really missing
from this hearing was somebody from the
department of education
to bring up you know because in my time
didn't you need at the age of 16 a
workers permit to go out there and work
and you tell me think back in your
history all your friends
who took that i'm only going to take one
year off of college
but they took that one year off and they
made some money and they never went back
it's very hard to do how can you get
somebody to pay attention to their
studies if they have a license
and
making money then you're throwing their
education this is a slippery slope i am
not going to support this thank you
thank you madam chair
i guess i agree with everybody starting
from representative pearson on
so many comments
i was kind of surprised
to hear some of the reasons
put forward by those who are promoting
ought to pass
citing the statements made by the
sponsor i found during the hearing
that he did not seem to have very clear
answers to a lot of the questions that
were put forward to him
indicating to me that the bill was not
really well thought out at all
and my personal feeling is that it
leaves
young people open to exploitation for
particularly things like
massage parlors
so that's the reason that i will be
voting against octopass and
hoping that we can
instead make this bill itl thank you
representatives
thank you i mean uh
in my view some of the uh previous
comments which i agree with including uh
representative o'brien and the one on
276a helped make the point that
there isn't a need for ages in any of
these
that's covered by other things and it's
just duplicative
thank you
representative goalie
thank you madam chair and not to belabor
the issue but i i do agree with my
colleagues
when you talk about child labor laws and
some of the other things in there
but i also do agree in part on some of
these when you have age requirements i'm
not sure how many doogie houses new
hampshire has but when you look at the
qualifications needed
at 18 years old for licensing
qualifications for optometry
i'm sure there's not too many under 18
that can meet those qualifications and
that those are there's a few in there
where you could actually look at and say
do we really need an age limit on them
because it's
before 18 you're not going to attain
those qualifications but when i look at
the other ones that we're repealing
especially section nine you go right
down the list from home inspectors
septic system evaluators
barber and cosmetology uh pharmacists
embalmers occupational therapists and so
on and so on um i i think there is an
area and a reason to keep minimum age
requirements in those occupations and so
i will vote against the at the past
representative
well i'll reluctantly support the otp i
prefer an interim study to look at these
more carefully on a case-by-case basis
because the fact is the people who
originally proposed these this
legislation picked these numbers out of
the air
there was no thought given to well 18
works here 19 works there
there's
this was just
off the shelf uh it's the way we did it
the last bill
so i'm
just i'm disturbed by that i would like
uh
to see
more thought given to the bill but to
make the statement i will vote for ought
to pass
the other thing is child labor laws that
kind of thing this not we're not talking
about that's different than licensing
this is whether you're going to work at
market basket
those laws stay in place there's nothing
changed about that and as far as the
massage parlors all that criminal
activity is a criminal activity it's not
going to change because of licensing
crime it's a misdemeanor is a
misdemeanor regardless of how
whether there's a license involved or
not so although i have no particular
love for the bill or for the shabby
presentation i'll vote for this to make
to make the statement i'd like to see
somebody actually examine
whether
ages are really appropriate for these uh
as a restriction
okay thank you
any other comments
all right thank you the motion is
inexpedient to legislate excuse me this
ought to pass on house bill 1460.
ought to pass yes
representative lekkis
made the motion
the clerk can call the roll
okay representative rhodes
no
the clerk obstinately votes yes
representative pearson no
representative
yes
representative allegro no
represent bailey
yes
representative lonzara no
representative santo anastaso yes
representative goalie
no
representative short
no representative judy not mr
representative marsh
no representative fellows no
representative font no
no
representative grota
no representative o'brien no the chair
yes
okay two four six yes
twelve no
okay the motion
fails six yes twelve no does someone
wish to make an alternate motion
representative marsh yes madam chair i
will move in expedient to legislate
all second okay
that's ending is speeding to legislate
by representative marsh seconded by
representative schuett
do you wish to speak to your motion
uh i i think what i said before applies
uh this is in contradiction to other law
and it does not have a place in our
statutes
okay representative schuett
ditto
okay does anyone else wish to speak
representatives just um briefly it's i
don't see it as a contradiction but it
doesn't overrule the other the previous
law we're not setting the age at 12 or
something it just
takes it out of this statute and lets it
be dealt with uh
through the others thank you
okay anyone else wishes
representative pearson so one of the
things thank you madam chair one of the
things that happens is that when you
when the state issues someone a license
to do certain things that it's not an
endorsement of their work but it is an
endorsement of potentially their
ability to do work
in in certain areas so
i i think it is of concern even though
potentially
yes human trafficking and things of that
nature are not
are not legal certainly
but providing licenses for
someone in that that's underage that
now we're starting to get into the
position of being okay with them
performing in this world just not
necessarily
how their performance is going so
i think that there's a little bit of an
implied um
not it's not the word permission but
when someone's licensed
their what they're doing has been kind
of codified by the state and i think
that that sends a particularly bad
message in some of these areas
representative allegra
thank you
i could echo almost all of the
points that i've heard made so far on
both sides frankly of the argument
uh but
we do make a distinction already
uh between
minor
those that have not reached the age of
majority in those that have
in many areas as representative o'brien
pointed out smoking and there's voting
and there's the draft and there's all
sorts of things so i'm not
um innately opposed to making that
distinction here
and then really just
uh representative pearson also almost
stole my thunder by just
pointing out that in the in the very act
of licensing and certifying the state or
whatever board we're talking about has
made
using the dictionary lest there be
misunderstanding the dictionary meaning
of the word discrimination they're
making a discriminating determination
that people that are 16 17 years old um
are highly unlikely to be qualified for
performing this duty
and um
with that discrimination again the
dictionary term
uh with that discrimination
they're putting their um
their judgment on the line
and so i i again i'm echoing
representative pearson's comments
it's
are these people truly going to be
qualified to perform some of the
functions that they're expected to
perform
so um
i'll be supporting the itl thank you
senator fellows
thank you
i'm supporting the ipi tl but i i just
wanted to point out that
you know maybe there
maybe there should should be some kind
of minimum age on some of these things
and also
i think some of these occupations
require a criminal background check
and so if somebody really wanted to to
to attack the
age discrimination thing i think they'd
have to do a lot more homework because
some of them require background checks
so how are you going to do that on a on
a juvenile i mean you're not going to be
able to see that record
yes representative lackas
i'm sorry i'll just say then they're not
going to get the license i mean i mean
there's many things that would stand in
the way of someone
who was too young uh getting licensed
which is again why i say it's do it's
just duplicative that's all
i will mention that when i rewrote some
of this when we're amending some of the
statutes we should look at the age
requirement and see if it's actually
necessary in that particular uh
and for that particular profession
because
it must be at least 18 and have a
phd is
kind of redundant and i believe that's
the current requirement for pharmacists
anyone else
all right see
seeing no other comments the motion is
itl on house bill 1460 and the clerk
will call the roll
representative rhodes
yes
columbus no
representative pearson yes
representative jacob
no
representative
representative allegro yes
represent bailey
no
representative lanzara yes
representative santos
no
representative goalie yes representative
short
yes
representative judy wheat mr
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota
yes representative o'brien yes and the
chair
no
12 6 ital
okay the motion passes
12 to 6.
i don't think consent is appropriate
it will will somebody want to write a
minority report representative lekkis
will write a minority report
all right
all right does anyone else have a bill
they think is ready for
um
for exec
it's barely three o'clock we've got
plenty of time
i see seeing no volunteers
yes that's true representative
please please no no no no no don't do it
fine
i think i don't want to do that
in any event the
we do have three early bills that we
will be voting on tomorrow in the late
afternoon
and
i understand representative judy will
have a replacement
i expect all the red if any of the rest
yes representative marshall uh yes madam
chair this is not a bill that's ready
but i have another amendment for
1566 and i'd like to pass it out so that
people have it we will be delighted to
add it to our piles of paper
thank you
okay and we'll discuss it tomorrow after
the hearing on the other amendment
you will have a replacement you won't
you will okay fine no problem
we will uh see you all then
and everybody who made a motion needs
that passed needs to write a committee
report
as soon as possible like right now
well i'm there with you
those boys
okay
you guys
no just one
no sorry for
14.97
we'll discuss what we're gonna do
we know where you are
and
i ended up calling the number back and
he got it
well i'm glad about that okay so you
will
14 14 29 yes i think
is
all right
in the morning
until after that okay
[Music]
i've got emails
you